And it was good to be, I love being here, but it was good to be away last week too.
It's good to be back again.
I was actually at a concert last weekend and if you'll let me, I'll talk your ear off about
it.
It was great, but I bought the tickets to this concert a little while back and it was
for the 25th anniversary of the soundtrack to A Brother Where Art Thou.
And so if you've never heard that soundtrack, it's great.
But I bought the tickets before they announced any of the lineup.
All they announced was that the concert was going to happen and the tickets were
cheap at the time because they hadn't announced anybody.
And all that I knew was that T-Bone Burnett was the one who was organizing the concert.
And if you've never heard his name before, he is the guy who produced that album years ago.
And so although I didn't know the lineup, I was confident that if he was
leading the thing, it was going to be amazing.
And it did not disappoint.
Say that to say, we don't always have to know the details of where we're going as
long as we can trust the one who is leading us there.
And this morning we're going to look at a passage that shows us,
above all, we can trust in God, even though we don't always understand
the road he is leading us down.
So we're going to look together at Exodus chapter 15 and chapter 16.
We're going to begin our reading in verse 22 of Exodus 15.
That's there in your worship guides.
And then we're going to go down to chapter 16 verse 4 and we'll read verses 11 and 12 as well.
So I'll begin reading in verse 22.
Then Moses made Israel set out from the Red Sea.
And they went into the wilderness of Shur.
They went three days in the wilderness and found no water.
When they came to Mara, they could not drink the water of Mara because it was bitter.
Therefore, it was named Mara.
And the people grumbled against Moses saying, what shall we drink?
And he cried to the Lord and the Lord showed him a log and
he threw it into the water.
And the water became sweet.
There the Lord made for them a statute and a rule.
And there he tested them saying, if you will diligently listen to the voice of the Lord your God
and do that which is right in his eyes and give ear to his commandments and
keep all his statutes, I will put none of the diseases on you that I put on the Egyptians.
For I am the Lord your healer.
Then they came to Elam where there were 12 springs of water and
70 palm trees and they encamped there by the water.
They set out from Elam.
And all the congregation of the people of Israel came to the wilderness of sin,
which is between Elam and Sinai.
On the 15th day of the second month after they had departed from the land of Egypt,
and the whole congregation of the people of Israel grumbled against Moses and
Aaron in the wilderness.
And the people of Israel said to them, would that we had died by the hand of
the Lord in the land of Egypt when we sat by the meat pots and ate bread to the full.
For you have brought us into this wilderness to kill this whole assembly with hunger.
Then the Lord said to Moses, behold I'm about to rain bread from heaven for you.
And the people shall go out and gather a day's portion every day that I may test them,
whether they will walk in my law or not.
And go down to verse 11.
And the Lord said to Moses, I have heard the grumbling of the people of Israel.
Say to them, at twilight you shall eat meat, and in the morning you shall be filled
with bread.
Then you shall know that I am the Lord your God.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together.
But we thank you that you are a God who provides.
And we thank you for the provision of your word.
And Lord by your spirit I pray that you would open our eyes to see more of you in your word.
Show us more of Jesus we pray.
Change us into his likeness.
If we ask this in his name.
Amen.
Well over the last few weeks we've looked at this amazing account of the
account of redemption in the Exodus.
God brought his people out of Egypt and he's promised to bring them in to the
promised land.
Then in chapter 15 we saw that they had a song in their mouth and a spring in their
step once they had passed through the Red Sea they're now bound for the promised land.
The Lord is their strength and their salvation.
He's become their song.
But it doesn't take long before that song starts to change.
They go from singing praise to singing the blues if you will.
Before they get to the promised land they've got to pass through this place called the
wilderness.
The wilderness is this uncultivated desolate in between place that feels more like
a nuisance that they would rather get over with as quick as possible.
But this is a necessary part of God's plan for them to lead them to and through the
wilderness.
I think the wilderness wonderings have some real strong points of application for us
because life is full of what we might call in between places.
We all go through seasons of life where the season we're going through feels more
imposed than something we would have chosen.
We're in a time that feels like a delay that we would rather just get over with.
Our thoughts are elsewhere.
We want to get on to the next thing rather than being where we are now.
You might think of a student who is in school and just ready for it to be over
with.
Maybe an employee who is in a job and they don't like the job they want it to
be over they want a better job elsewhere.
Or maybe being part of a church that's still kind of forming and doesn't even
have a building yet.
You just kind of think where are we heading?
What's going on here?
It feels a bit like the wilderness.
This shows us that God has a purpose for His people even in the wilderness.
If we look at these places, these in between places as something that we just
want to get over with or get past, we might miss the important thing that God
wants to show us and teach us along the way right where we are.
And actually to take a step back, really all of the Christian life is an
in between place just like the wilderness.
If you put your faith in Jesus, you've been redeemed from slavery to sin and
death, but you haven't yet arrived in your final promised eternal home.
So just like the Israelites, we're in this in between place.
So what's God doing here?
What's His purpose in this?
Well, Exodus chapter three and verse 12, if you want to look back there, God told
Moses that his people were going to be brought out of Egypt so that they might
serve him.
So in the Exodus, Yahweh rescued his people from slavery, not just so they
might be liberated, but so that they might live in the freedom of trusting
him as their savior and king.
So if Exodus was about redemption, the wilderness is about transformation,
where God teaches us to follow Him as our King.
So in the same way, once again, our life with Christ begins at redemption,
but then begins the work of transformation.
We're trained to trust and follow Jesus to live as His disciples in the
world now.
We're not here for the eternal kingdom, but we're living under His reign right
now, and it takes time for us to learn that.
So for the next few moments, I want us to look at this by saying a few
things.
One is, why is the wilderness the place where the Lord transforms us?
Why has He chosen the wilderness for that?
Secondly, what God teaches us there in the wilderness.
And then lastly, we'll see how God helps us to remember what we
learned in the wilderness.
Why the wilderness?
Why has He chosen that place?
Well, the fact is there are certain lessons that can only be taught in the
wilderness, in places of need, places of hardship.
So if you look at a place like Psalm 119, in verse, it's either 7 or 17.
You'll have to look it up to figure out which one it was.
Here's what it says.
It was good for me that I was afflicted.
Imagine saying that.
Why?
Psalmist says, that I might learn your statutes.
It's in times of affliction that the Lord teaches us to trust in His
words and those times that He shapes us by His word.
So Israel's going through this time.
It feels like a time of affliction, a time of need.
I mean, so let's recount what they did here, what we just read.
So it's taken them three days to find any water.
So they're really feeling thirst.
And when they finally come to this water, they drink the water and
they spit it out.
It is bitter.
It's undrinkable.
That's why they call it mara.
The word means bitterness.
A month after that, after they've been given water, they're now
looking for food because they haven't had any food.
And so they're starting to get really, really hungry.
They're really feeling this.
Another bitterness starts to creep in.
So you say, well, what is God doing in their thirst, in their hunger?
Well, He tells us in verse 25 of chapter 15.
It says, there the Lord made for them a statute and a rule.
And it says, and there He marked this word, tested them.
If they will diligently listen to the voice of the Lord their
God and do what was right in His eyes.
That's been repeated in verse 4 of chapter 16.
He gave them food in the wilderness and He did this.
He says, that I might test them, whether they will walk in
my law or not.
So why the wilderness is because God wants to test His people.
Now that word might feel pretty negative to us.
They're thinking back to school and being tested.
And I was looking at the different places where the word is used in scripture.
And there's one place that's really, really helpful for getting to grips with the kind
of testing and speaking about here in the wilderness.
It's actually in 1 Samuel chapter 17 where David is going to go out and fight
Goliath and Saul, King Saul gives David his armor and his sword.
But it says David decides not to wear Saul's armor or to use his sword
because he hadn't yet proven them.
That's the same word for testing.
He hadn't yet tested them.
So what did he use instead?
He used his sling that he had had in the wilderness.
And he used the staff that he went out with those things.
So how does that tell us about what testing is all about?
So God wants to use His people to glorify His name.
So He brings them through a time of proving where He trains them to be the people
that He saved them to be.
So the wilderness is a time of training.
That's what we're talking about when it comes to testing.
And this testing that happens in the wilderness is a good way to reveal the things
that are in their hearts that need to be changed and dealt with and transformed.
All right. So this is what testing does.
It brings those things out from their hearts.
So let me read Deuteronomy chapter 8 and verse 2 later on kind of interpreting what happened in the wilderness.
It says,
Why did He do that?
Why did He lead them in the wilderness?
He tells us that He might humble you, testing you.
Why?
To know what was in your heart, whether you would keep His commandments or not.
So the hardship of the wilderness brought things in their hearts to the surface that need to be changed
and that comes out in their words.
So what words do the people of God use when they're thirsty and hungry?
It's not words of gratitude for sure.
It's not words of faith, not words of hope.
It tells us they were grumbling.
The words were just as bitter as the water they just spat out.
What did they say?
Let's read what they say in verse 3 of chapter 16 when they're hungry.
They said,
They said this to Moses,
For you have brought us into this wilderness to kill this whole assembly with hunger.
So they're wishing they were back in Egypt.
They'd better be slaves in Egypt than serving the Lord out in the wilderness.
They blame Moses.
The wilderness trial they faced, here's the thing, it did not cause this reaction.
It simply revealed what was already in their hearts.
Alright, so this is what Jesus said in Luke chapter 6.
Remember, he says that a good tree brings forth good fruit and a bad tree brings forth bad fruit.
But then he goes on to say,
Out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks.
So what the mouth is saying is revealing what is already in our hearts.
So all this is leading really to this.
As God leads us to the wilderness because hardship reveals the condition of our hearts.
You see, the Lord knows what's in our hearts, Jeremiah 17, 9 and 10.
The Lord only knows what's there.
But he uses these times of testing to bring what's in our hearts out so that we might see what's there.
To see what are the other things that we are chasing after or trusting in instead of him.
I don't have a cup with me.
Imagine I had a cup full of water here.
This is really simple, but I remember somebody sharing this with me one time.
It was really helpful.
They said, if you knock into that cup of water, what's going to come out?
Of course, water.
But you knocking into that cup of water didn't create the thing that was in the cup.
You knocking into it only revealed what was already there.
That's what is spilling out.
So the same thing is happening when we go through hardships.
They don't create the hardships.
Don't create the ungodly reactions that spill out of us in those times.
They simply reveal what was already there in the first place.
And so often we want to blame our reaction on our hardship.
So if they hadn't said this, I wouldn't have then said what I said.
So we blame the hardship on our reaction.
Or maybe we just try to fix things by changing the hard circumstances while
ignoring the deeper work that needs to take place on the inside of our own hearts.
Now that's not to say we don't ever seek to change hard circumstances.
I'm not saying that at all.
But what I am saying is oftentimes we focus on that and yet ignore the thing that the Lord is teaching us through it.
The thing that He wants to change inside of us.
You know we might come back at that and say well, the thing is my issue isn't with God at all.
My issue is with Him. My issue is with her.
My issue is with that.
But in chapter 16 and verse 8 here, we see that the people were reacting against their hunger.
They were reacting against Moses.
But it makes it clear that they were ultimately reacting against the Lord.
So this was about the Lord.
Their grumbling was about Him.
It was demonstrating that they weren't, either they were saying He's not sovereign over us or He's sovereign over us, but He is not good.
So their grumbling was ultimately about the Lord.
So why the wilderness?
Because hardship reveals the conditions of our hearts.
God brings us through seasons like this not to harm us,
but to humble us, to free us from the illusion of self-sufficiency.
There He teaches us that we can trust and follow Him.
Alright so what is He teaching us in the wilderness?
Let's give more of our focus there now.
So God doesn't just show them the condition of their hearts here in their grumbling.
He also reveals the glory of His grace to them as He provides what they need.
Isn't it wonderful that He does that here?
I just wanted to say praise God that He shows grace to grumblers.
So God's grace isn't poured out upon us because we are so deserving or because we've gotten it right.
Isn't it wonderful that passages like this where they were grumbling, they weren't grateful, they weren't trusting in the Lord.
So here's how He responds. He pours out His grace upon them.
Isn't it wonderful that He doesn't deal with us as our sin deserves.
He pours out His grace on our lives.
His provision shows us, so here's what He's teaching us.
It shows us who He is.
It shows us that we can depend upon Him.
It does this by providing different things.
Let's look at what God provides for His people here.
First of all, He provides physical nourishment.
He graciously supplies for their physical needs.
So in verse 25 of chapter 15, He gives them water for their thirst.
In fact, He shows Moses this log which He then throws into the bitter water and it makes it sweet.
So there's this miracle that takes place here.
And then after that, so they're able to drink the water, then after that He leads them to a place of,
where there's abundant springs of water, you see there in verse 27.
So He provides water for their thirst. He provides food for their hunger.
And when they're hungry, He then causes these quail to rain down from heaven so they can eat that.
So that falls in the evening.
And then you have this manna that appears in the morning that they can eat.
And then He provides rest for their weariness.
So chapter 16 is where we're introduced to the Sabbath.
The Sabbath laws here might feel like a restriction, but actually it's a gift from the Lord because He knows what they need.
He knows that they need rest. So He gives them rest.
So here God is putting His glory on display as the God who graciously and abundantly and daily cares for the needs of His people.
And this same God is the God who takes care of us today.
So you look in the New Testament, Philippians chapter 4 and verse 19.
Paul's writing to the church there that has been very generous to others.
And he says, my God shall supply all your need according to His riches in glory.
So God is going to put His glory on display.
How does God put His glory on display by providing what we need?
That doesn't mean that He always gives us what we want or what we think we need, when we think we need it.
But He always knows exactly what we need to honor Him exactly in this season of life for Him right now.
He's got it ready to provide it for us for the glory of His name.
Now actually we can look through the different ways He provides here and it maps over onto how He provides for us now.
If you look at chapter 15 verse 25, we see, well yeah, actually sometimes God does miraculously change our circumstances.
He makes our bitter waters sweet and He provides for us in that way.
Sure.
And there are other times, like when you get to verse 27, when God takes us from this bitter place we are in to another place.
Where there's abundant springs of water and He brings us into a new situation and provides for us in that way.
But I also want to make clear that there are other times when our circumstances do not change and even in the middle of that He shows us that He is enough.
We can say I can do all things through Christ who gives me strength.
I can go through times of plenty or times of need because He is enough.
Isn't it wonderful He provides daily too.
He doesn't tell them to gather a year's worth or even a month's worth.
You know, we want to plan everything in advance.
He says, you can trust me daily.
So this is an invitation to live a life of daily dependence on the Lord.
To pray as Jesus taught us to pray, give us this day our daily bread.
The thing is, He provides nourishment for their bodies with something else in view too.
And that is the nourishment their souls need.
It's the same nourishment our souls need because He provides them with His Word.
You see, this isn't ultimately about water and bread.
This is about the Word of the Lord.
So you see that in Exodus 15 verse 26.
God explicitly says that this test is about not whether or not they're going to have water.
It's about whether or not they're going to listen to His Word and do what He says.
Then in chapter 16, you see that when He provides bread, it comes with these instructions as to how they are to collect the bread.
These commandments related to the Sabbath.
They were to collect double before the Sabbath days.
They're able to observe that day as a day of rest and worship.
You see, in these commands that He has given, in His Word, we're seeing this is about more than taking care of physical needs.
I love how one commentator helpfully put it.
He said, this is not about filling their bellies, but shepherding their hearts.
So God is teaching them not only that they should follow His ways.
So yeah, His Word is about that. Yeah, there's commands.
So yeah, He's teaching us we should follow His ways, but also He's doing this.
He's saying, you should follow my ways because you can trust in my goodness.
Trusting His goodness is seen when we listen to His Word and we live it out because we know we can trust in Him.
So the big question is here is, do they trust Him enough, His goodness enough to obey what He says?
The answer to that is unfortunately not.
When they go out to gather bread, some of them try to hoard some, to have their own supplies ready for another day.
And you've got others who are going out on the Sabbath day and they're wondering where the food is.
So instead of following God's commands the day before or resting in His gracious provision as He provided it,
they're taking matters into their own hands and they're falling back upon self-reliance and self-rule.
And if we're willing to admit it, I think we can all say that there are plenty of times when we do the same.
Jesus taught us in Matthew 6.33 to seek first His kingdom and His righteousness.
And all that we need will be provided for us.
But how often do we think and live as though everything was down to us?
We say we serve a God whose grace is sufficient but all too quickly we fall back into patterns of self-reliance and self-rule.
And our thoughts and our attitudes and our actions.
And the thought that God by His word is withholding some good from us is a lie that's as old as the Garden of Eden.
If we think a better life is found outside of the boundaries that He has laid out for us, that's where we'll soon go.
We look at the boundaries He's set in His word, His commands, and we think,
well actually there's a good thing that I can have over here.
So God must be withholding some better life from me.
So we push beyond the boundaries.
You see the life of obedience that God calls us to flows from a heart that trusts in His goodness.
As we do that we discover that we can flourish even in the wilderness.
The fact is God's word is not only true but it's also good and the path that He lays out for us is always best.
And here's some wonderful news too.
Once again back to the failure of the people of Israel.
Even when we wander outside the bounds of that good path, He is still gracious.
He draws us back to Himself and He trains us once again that we can trust in Him.
Following Him is best.
This is ultimately though, it's about Him, it's about His glory.
You see that in chapter 6 and verse 12.
When He feeds His people, He does it and He says,
and then you shall know that I am the Lord your God.
This is about the I am.
This is ultimately about Jesus.
You see, yeah, we fail but Jesus succeeded where Israel failed and where we fail.
When Jesus was tempted in the wilderness, He trusted in the Word of God.
And then when He went out and He faced hungry multitudes, He also had compassion on them
because this is the same shepherd who's with His people.
He has compassion upon them and He teaches them and He feeds them as well.
Then one of the accounts of that is in John chapter 6.
After people had eaten some of that food, they come back to Jesus.
And they're not all that interested in Him but they do want some more of the food He was providing.
So they come back to Him, they want Him to perform another miracle and give them some more food.
And He sees that and so He says something to them that is so profound that we need to hear.
John 6.35, Jesus says, I am the bread of life.
Whoever comes to me shall never hunger. Whoever believes in me shall never thirst.
You see, this is what God's provision in the wilderness is pointing us to.
It's pointing us to Jesus because He is the bread that came down from heaven.
He is the one who gives us eternal life.
He is the one who satisfies the longing of our souls.
And He is the one who gives us rest.
So Matthew 11, 28, Jesus says, come to me all you who labor and are heavy laden and I will give you rest.
So what does God teach us in the wilderness?
He shows us who He is.
He shows us this in His Word, in providing for us daily but He ultimately shows us who He is in the person of His Son.
In Jesus we see that we can depend on the Lord.
And in the wilderness as we look to Jesus, God shapes us into His likeness.
Remember the wilderness is about transformation and this happens as we learn to trust in the goodness of God revealed in Jesus.
And as we look to Him, God changes us to be more gracious people that reflects the goodness and graciousness of our Savior.
I wish we could study two more chapters this morning.
In 2 Corinthians chapter 8 and chapter 9, Paul actually references God providing manna in the wilderness there.
And he talks about God being gracious to His people and God showing us grace in Jesus.
But in those chapters it's all about our generosity and giving to others in need.
As he shows us, we've been given this grace in Jesus so that transforms us to be a people who are generous in our giving toward others.
That's just one example of how seeing God's grace in Jesus changes us and makes us gracious people instead of a grumbling, self-centered people.
So after he's taught them these things, or as he's teaching these things, he also gives them a teaching aid.
He gives them a reminder. And this is the last thing I want us to see briefly.
He gives them some help to remember what he's teaching them in the wilderness.
In chapter 16 verses 31 to 36, God gives them a jar of manna.
He tells them to take some of this manna and put it in a jar.
And they were going to place this in the Ark of the Covenant and they were going to put it before the testimony.
And that's the Ten Commandments. These are things that are yet to be given.
But as they travel through the wilderness there to have this jar of manna that's going to go with them,
and remind generations to come of how the Lord graciously provided for them in the wilderness.
Some of our most valuable things that we have at home aren't valuable at all in terms of money,
but they're valuable to us because of sentimental value.
We love to have things of where we've traveled.
So we've got a park we used to love to go to and they had these 800-year-old trees.
And our kids used to play inside these trees.
So before we moved from England, we went to that park one last time and I went up to that 800-year-old tree.
Don't tell anybody.
And I ripped off a piece of bark and I took it with us.
And so we've got that piece of bark sitting on a bookshelf at home kind of reminding us of that good place we enjoyed together as a family.
More recently, we've loved traveling to Gulf State Park.
And we camp there and we love seeing the little alligators that are there.
And so I went and bought an alligator head.
And so we've got that alligator head on that same bookshelf.
So all these little reminders along the way of places that we've been that have been good reminders for us.
But you know, we've also gotten, I brought it this morning, we've got another little reminder and that's a painting that's over there.
And I don't think the painting is worth much necessarily, but it's worth so much to us because it reminds us of a particular time in our lives where I had been called to pastor a church.
And as we were in this community and starting into it, we realized like we can't really afford to live in the community where I've been called to pastor this church.
Now, there's no way we'll be able to afford a mortgage to have a house here.
And so we prayed about it. Nothing seemed to happen.
I remember talking to Julia and I said, well, how far off are we financially from being able to actually get a mortgage?
And she gave a very specific number and we thought, well, yeah, that's unattainable.
And so only a few days later, a couple from the church got in touch with us and the wife is an artist.
And they said, well, we wanted to give this anonymously, but we have to like present a letter to the bank so you would notice.
We just want to tell you anyway, we want to give, to help you to get a house in this area.
And it was the exact amount that Julie had just said a few days ago.
We were there praying, Lord, this seems impossible and the Lord provided.
And that's a couple of, they're so generous.
And one day she decided she was just going to give some of her paintings away.
And so we got one of those paintings.
So we have that painting up in our house and it's just a daily reminder.
Like this hasn't come from us.
This has come from the Lord who provides for our daily needs.
You know, there's nothing in the New Testament, by the way, that prescribes us having like tangible objects like around our house or whatever.
But it doesn't forbid it either.
So I think it's, you know, it is a good practice to have little reminders here and there that says, you know, this is where the Lord provided for us.
Certainly we see that pattern throughout the Old Testament, these reminders along the way of the Lord's goodness.
Maybe it's a prayer journal for you where you jot down where the answers of prayer have come.
The important thing is that we remember how the Lord is provided so that we might retell them for generations to come that they too might know and trust in the Lord.
But you know, when you come to the New Testament, the Lord has given us a tangible reminder of the greatest thing he has provided for us.
Hasn't he?
He's given us this reminder of the bread of life.
The greatest gift, which is the Lord Jesus who gave his life.
And he died so that we might live.
Let's hear these words from 1 Corinthians 11.
It says, the Lord Jesus on the night when he was betrayed took bread.
When he had given thanks, he broke it and said, this is my body, which is for you.
Do this in remembrance of me.
In the same way, he took the cup.
After supper saying, this cup is the new covenant in my blood.
Do this as often as you drink it in remembrance of me.
For as often as you eat this bread and drink this cup, you proclaim the Lord's death until he comes.
So Jesus died that we might live.
He is the one who satisfies the longing of our souls.
When we partake in this bread and wine by faith, we remember and proclaim his death until he comes.
And this is a reminder wherever we end up in the coming months and years.
It's a reminder we'll take with us.
We've got the bread and the wine to remind us of the true bread of life.
So I'd like for you to invite us to come to the Lord's table.
That we might taste and see that the Lord is good.
So let's pray together before we come.
Lord, all too often we are a people who, instead of looking at your abundant grace that you've shown us in Jesus,
focus on ourselves, focus on our problems, we grumble and complain.
And all the while, Lord, you are reigning.
You're working all things together for our good.
Lord, we thank you that you look upon people like us, sinful people,
and you pour out your grace upon us in Jesus.
Lord, I pray that you would humble us even now.
And Lord, that you would show us the sufficiency of your grace.
And Lord, we thank you that Jesus took all of our sin upon himself.
Lord, he died in our place.
And Lord, we thank you that we can receive him by faith,
knowing that in him you graciously receive us to yourself.
So Lord, as we come to your table this morning, help us to be looking to Jesus by faith.
Lord, as we receive this bread and receive this cup,
I pray that in our hearts we would taste and see, Lord, that you truly are good.
I pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.